So how to be successful with SCO.
The first thing that we need to remember
is first of all not to overdo it and
not to underestimate it.
Back in the day you could make
a lot of money with SCO just by
exchanging links and optimizing for
specific keywords on your website.
That was amazing.
That was the gold rush of SCO.
But that's not happening anymore.
A lot of websites
are getting slapped and
a lot of people who made a lot of money
are not making that money anymore.
And they don't have
a choice because what
was working back then
is not working anymore.
And the best thing that you
should remember with about SCO
is that it's the most the relevancy
of your offering to the audience.
And when people
are using search engines,
they are basically asking questions.
So if you'll think about it,
if you're typing into the search engine,
cheap clothes New York.
We're basically asking a question,
right?
Where can I find cheap
clothes in New York?
Or what kind of cheap clothes
can I find in New York?
And so on and so forth.
So you want your website
to be ranked in the top.
So you want to create some kind
of answers to those questions.
So if we are thinking also about
what kind of content to create, so
we need to entertain,
or we need to educate.
We need also to answer questions.
One of the most important things is
how to know which keyword
we should invest on.
There are so many keywords.
People are arriving to our site using
50,000 different kinds of keywords.
Some of them are even titles.
So they were branded, that they were
using our name, some of them were not.
How can we know what to use?
So there's a lot of ways, similarly is
one of them that you can search for
the keywords that are leading
users to your competitors,
the keywords that are leading users
to the websites on mobile apps that
you think are similar to yours.
And you can start and
finding those keywords,
creating the list, and then you know
what kind of content to create and
what kind of questions
you want to answer on.
You want really to avoid nasty tricks,
black header CO.
This can be very gratifying
in the beginning.
You can get a lot of users, but
you'll eventually get slapped.
It happened in the past,
it will happen in the future.